it is the season it is Christmas and I'm
curious you are a a German fellow
earlier in the show we had a little
comedy sketch featuring Krampus I think
the Germans call him Krampus well so for
Christmas
we have you guys have a fun Santa man he
is fun and up and down and jelly bean
and what what what mistletoe yeah yeah
no we have a fear-based holiday is our
Christmas as you know children or yeah
children or [ __ ] yes yes so children
as we know children are [ __ ] and so
you need to be scaring them so they are
quiet and very much just please just eat
your beef jerky and do your algebra
please so that is the German philosophy
is scare the child because the child
deserves to be scared that's correct so
we have created a team of scary monsters
for Christmas like have you seen the
show Chia's yeah it's like this but all
of the cast members eat babies yeah yeah
and so what these characters they're
really scary to kids holy good cow cow
yeah have you seen that you met out well
Krampus yeah I know about Krampus
Krampus is not to give you the feels in
May yeah I always go but no well not
specifically that but yeah yes Krampus
is very scary yeah well accomplice to a
tribe's he's going to make a freak out
or she all the genders will make a freak
out with compass he's an equal trend are
terrified okay all right I think you
have a you brought a picture of this is
real adults dresses cramp booster scared
children is that right yes these are
actually parents that's horrifying
why that's it's just terrifying look at
that child that child is not having fun
is that tried do you see a misbehaving
no he's behaving
he's behaving there any any female
Christmas characters in Germany yes
Conan O'Brien we are equal genders
everywhere I'm of course and so we have
kalpesh Da Lat Frau Pech Turkish - she's
not quite aligned pH - she is married
yeah we have not seen the husband for
many generations yeah but if you are
rude to foppish that she will remove
your internal organs Oregon Oregon's yes
organs right why do you have a state
named we don't that's Oregon that's or
again that is not Oregon it's different
not that's no we didn't name the state
your intestines now that seems like an
odd that would have been an odd thing to
do what choice like who did that
no no one did that Flula okay so can
okay sorry
so the organs we have replaced we've
replaced these organs with trash that is
what she does wait so she takes she
opens people up and she takes out their
organs and then replaces it with trash
do replaces to Oregons with trash we
have a theory we think she is the first
German to have started recycling in this
way yeah what watch
you